[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Welcome to this
episode of "Click to Deploy,"
a series where we
show you how easy it
is to deploy solutions from
the Google Cloud Marketplace.
In this episode,
we'll be reviewing
how to set up FortiGate
Next-Generation Firewall
virtual appliance, FortiGate-VM,
via the Cloud Marketplace.
In case you're
unfamiliar, FortiGate-VM
delivers the same firewall
and secure SD-WAN capabilities
for organizations of all
sizes, similar to those
offered by Fortinet's
industry-leading solutions.
It enables broad content
and network protection.
Plus, it automates management
for consistent enforcement
and visibility across your
hybrid cloud infrastructure.
Let's start by
searching for FortiGate
in the Cloud Marketplace.
We'll choose this solution,
FortiGate Next-Generation
Firewall, PAYG.
To deploy FortiGate,
we need to ensure
that the Compute Engine, Cloud
Deployment, and Cloud Runtime
APIs have been enabled.
Before we choose our specs, make
sure to review the usage fee
for choosing this solution,
which shows you infrastructure
fees for choosing the solution
based on VM instance and SSD.
Let's choose our specs.
We'll start with
deployment name.
For this tutorial, I'll
choose fortigate-101.
Then zone-- let's
choose us-central1.
Next, machine family-- we will
choose series E2 and e2-medium
with two vCPUs, which provides
day-to-day computing at a lower
cost.
Then boot disk-- we'll choose
SSD Persistent Disk and a boot
disk size of 10 gigabytes.
For log disk, we'll
enable log disk
and use the default.
For FortiGate,
we'll choose the most recent
image version of 7.0.2.
Finally, firewall--
depending on your needs,
you can choose what type of
connection you will allow
and for what IP
address ranges, if any.
For this tutorial, we
will leave all selected.
Click the Deploy button
to launch the solution.
As you can see, our FortiGate
firewall has been deployed.
Let's log in to the
Admin panel and change
the temporary password.
You'll find the admin user
and temporary password right
on the Deployment Manager.
There you have it.
FortiGate
Next-Generation Firewall
deployed with the
click of a button.
If you enjoyed this video,
please subscribe and hit
the Like button below.
We encourage you to check out
the Google Cloud Marketplace
and deploy this
solution on your own.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]